bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
charlotte gressier bonjour vous êtes la
présidente de héritage 9 7 2 une
association de type loi 1901 nous allons
y revenir mais la jeune citoyenne
française de martinique que vous êtes
comment réagit-elle au décès annoncé
hier du président de la république de
l'ex président la république jacques
chirac
oui écoutez je pense que c'est comme
tous les français
martiniquais c'est comme si on perdait
un membre de la famille j'ai l'occasion
de le rencontrer et je pense que ce qui
m'a marqué le plus c'est que c'est sa
sincérité en fait ce qu'on fait on
trouve pas forcément chez les politiques
en tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui était
venu lui qui s'est déplacée plusieurs
fois aux antilles et qui a bien rappelé
qu'on était français ça je pense que
c'est très important et c'est une espèce
de mode elle aussi alors là une fois
précédentes où vous étiez dans sa au
caddie vous étiez la référente de la
république en marche en martinique
depuis les choses ont changé finalement
cette aventure en tant que référente de
la reine n'aura duré qu'un an
et qu'est ce que cela vous a apporté
justement cette année de représentation
du mouvement politique résidentiel de la
majorité présidentielle même permis en
fait de devoir un petit peu les arcanes
de la politique comment cela fonctionne
les dysfonctionnements également et de
voir qu'il ya d'autres manières de
s'engager
et puis c'était aussi une question
d'intégrité gêné ducation simplement et
des principes
donc voilà j'ai respecté ce que mes
parents m'ont appris et donc
l'engagement citoyen via une association
le paraissait plus approprié plus
sincères donc vous avez démissionné de
cette fonction de ce mandat de référente
de la république en marche et donc vous
avez créé cette association dénommée
héritage 9 7 2 héritage au pluriel
pourquoi ce nom que signifie t'il
charlotte gris si je trouvais important
en fait de rendre hommage à nos pères et
quand je dis père cprs mais prs aussi
parce que je suis fondamentalement
convaincu delà du pouvoir de la
transmission est du devoir de
transmission aussi héritage avec un s
parce que c'est vrai que on a une
histoire qui est tellement tellement
riche je pense qu'il faut absolument
qu'on s'appuie là-dessus et en sachant
d'où l'on vient je pense qu'on peut
savoir à peu près où l'on va donc voilà
+972 de ces martinique parce que je
pense que la martinique peut être force
de proposition et ça peut être une
impulsion martiniquaise alors c'est une
cette association
en fait c'est pour avoir des actions
citoyennes
c'est ça avec notamment cette académie
des super-héros martiniquais dit aussi
quelques mots oui en fait je suis parti
d'un constat simple c'est que je me suis
dit avec tout ce qu'on a vécu
alors que ce soit les catastrophes
naturelles économiques environnementales
aussi je me suis dit on est toujours
debout
on est toujours là et ça je crois qu'on
en oublie qu'on a cette capacité lors
certains parlent de résilience je dirais
simplement qu'il ya ce côté super héros
c'est à dire qu'on est toujours debout
et et puis vous avez aussi tous les
héros du quotidien qui sont en fait les
gens qui sont au travail et les gens qui
sont trop digne pour pour se plaindre
fait et je me suis dit qu'il fallait
aussi à vendre certaines ambitions
scène ça n'empêche pas d'où cette idée
de pouvoir dire aux gens oser et vous
êtes capable aussi de prendre des
décisions notamment au niveau des
communes puisque vous êtes les meilleurs
ambassadeurs de ce qui ne va pas mais
aussi de ce qui va alors vous voulez
effectivement donné envie dites-vous aux
citoyens martiniquais de s'impliquer
évidemment en politique notamment dans
le cadre des prochaines échéances
électorales les élections municipales on
y reviendra
mais voilà alors vous voulez non
seulement suscité donc des vocations
donné cette envie de s'impliquer en
politique mais vous dites il faut quand
même une base on peut pas y aller comme
ça et donc votre crédo c'est qu'il faut
proposer de la formation et que les
citoyennes et citoyens martiniquais bah
voilà soto forment en fait face de
l'autoformation où se fasse formé par
par d'autres peut-être plus plus
expérimenté mais mais c'est bien ça le
le principe oui alors le principe c'est
vraiment de déjà de se sentir légitime
parce qu'en fait j'ai rencontré beaucoup
de gens c'est vrai que je suis allé en
commune aussi combien souvent mais de
manière très bien très concrète et vous
avez beaucoup de porteurs de projets qui
malheureusement aussi quitte beaucoup la
martinique est de plus en plus et
certains se disent je ne suis pas
capable donc là c'était simplement de
leur dire vous pouvez le faire vous avez
besoin d'outils en revanche donc de
manière tout à fait sereine j'ai cherché
aussi une personne qui voudrait bien
transmettre parce que les gens sachent
plus âgées qui veulent transmettre et on
n'a pas beaucoup non plus en tout cas en
martinique j'ai eu du mal à les trouver
donc j'ai cherché et c'est vrai que
c'est en france que j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un qui écrit un guide pratique
christian proust pour oser s'impliquer
dans la politique locale et il a fait
donc le déplacement et il ne s'est pas
montré comme un spécialiste aussi on
n'était pas dans une conférence élitiste
un peu une réunion de famille alors on
va y revenir puisque vous faites
allusion à cette conférence qui dit à
lui qui a eu lieu il ya quelques jours
c'était le 14 septembre dernier
mais d'abord cette association héritage
9 7 2 charlotte gressier certains vont
peut-être se dire oui d'accord une
association pour commencer mais est-ce
que c'est pas finalement un embryon de
parti
et puis quel intérêt pour vous pour vous
à titre personnel en tant que femme
politique ou en tout cas citoyenne
faisant partit donc du personnel
politique de la martinique quel intérêt
pour vous d'être là à la présidence de
cette association
alors je sais qu'il faut souvent que je
le répète mais c'est vrai que je viens
de la société civile je vois là donc
j'ai décidé de franchir le pas et c'est
aussi parce que j'ai franchi le pas que
je dis c'est possible après il faut être
curieux il faut avoir du culot et il
faut être constant alors ça c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué donc l'association
loi 1901 ça me paraissait le plus simple
quand on a envie de commencer je peux
vous dire aussi que de manière très
concrète et très sincère 7 évolutif
c'est pour ça que la conférence était
une conférence test parce que je suis
pas don quichotte non plus j'ai pas la
vérité absolue
je me manque pas non plus comme une
experte en politiques publiques
quoique j'ai quand même une
spécialisation en gestion des
collectivités territoriales mais venant
de la société civile donc si vous voulez
c'est une démarche vraiment associative
pour dire aux gens de venir y une
démarche associative au début mais est
ce qu elle peut se transformer ce
qu'elle peut prendre un autre cours
cette démarche est à ce que héritage 9 7
2 a vocation à devenir un mouvement ou
un parti politique
pour moi ça terme l'objectif vraiment
c'est ce qui s'est passé j'étais
agréablement surprise de voir que vous
alliez 16 communes représentées lors de
la conférence qui est quand même des
gens qui sont venus de gros-morne de
trinité du carbet jusqu aux anses
d'arlet qui ont fait cette démarche là
des gens qui ne connaissaient pas la
politique qui voulaient s'y intéresser
et vous avez déjà quatre ou cinq liste
citoyenne qui se sont ébauchés l'heure
où avant la conférence va pas dire non
plus que c'est grâce à nous mais on a
aussi impulsé cette chose là et d'autres
lisent et citoyennes se sont voilà des
risques et citoyenne en vue des
munitions des municipales de mai
prochain
oui imaginez quatre ou cinq ça peut
vraiment changer la donne et dans des
communes différentes
et en plus avec des gens autonomes je
descends pas téléguidé ce sont des gens
qui savent exactement où ils vont ils
sont venus prendre des contenus
informatifs pour pouvoir développer
leurs connaissances de base donc
donc ce n'est pas à exclure que à un
moment donné ça puisse se transformer
éventuellement donc en parti politique
ou en mouvement dans la mesure où les
lits citoyenne son délit citoyenne qui
peuvent être de n'importe quelle
étiquette vous pouvez avoir n'importe
qui moi je suis pas là pour dire moins
coûté vaut mieux être tel ou tel parti
vous pouvez aussi être bas ne pas faire
partie d'un parti
voilà vous pouvez monter votre les
citoyennes après vous êtes ce que vous
voulez moi je suis parti d'un constat
simple j'ai pris les travaux
d'universitaires martiniquais qui montre
ce que sera la martinique dans 50 ans et
quand j'ai vu les littoraux qui était
totalement érodée avec des communes qui
disparaît je me suis dit bon là il n'y a
pas de d'étiquette politique il faut il
faut avancer
alors mais le soutien à emmanuel macron
tout ça parce que vous vous en cachez
pas en même temps vous vous dites que
vous restez toujours elle en tout cas
vous tenez la cause du président de la
république
alors c'est vrai que moi j'ai quitté la
république en argent j'ai surtout
quitter l'as public en marche parce que
justement ça ne correspondait pas du
tout à ce que défendent et le président
de la république il y avait un décalage
liés à l'entourage comme on peut trouver
au niveau national
donc ce décalage la faisait que je ne
pouvais pas respecté les éléments de
langage qu'on me donnait mais la
majorité présidentielle oui enfin moi
j'ai pas de problème avec ça parce que
il faut quelqu'un qui est cette espèce
d'ambition de pouvoir aller aussi au
delà de prendre des risques
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui la poigne
je pense qu'on manque de gens de poigne
aussi alors nous faisait allusion à
cette conférence du 14 septembre dernier
qui a eu lieu donc aux anses d'arlet
effectivement avec la présence de
christian proust vous le disais auteur
du guide pratique pour oser s'impliquer
dans la vie politique locale disait que
c'était une conférence test qui
permettaient ainsi d'évaluer aussi la
motivation des martiniquaises et des
martiniquais qui étaient là deux de vos
compatriotes à changer les choses
vous dites c'est ce que vous avez
expliquer un petit peu tout à l'heure
c'est chose faite vous avez comment
dirais je vous avait décelé
effectivement une motivation va
peut-être mettre une forte motivation de
certains citoyens à s'engager
oui là une conférence de nations c'était
cette conférence test l'idée c'était de
voir comment ça se passait clairement il
ya motivation il ya une suite il n'y a
pas de motivation l'art est donc là il
ya une prochaine session ce sera des
modules d'information la date sera
précisée parce qu'il a fallu réorganiser
les choses et encore une fois l
engagement citoyen marsily clic comme
l'éclosion d'une fleur délicate vous
voyez donc il faut prendre le temps mais
je sens que les gens veulent y aller je
pense qu'on aura de belles surprises
enfin vous avez toutes les informations
de toute façon sur pas sur notre page 1
ça fait un petit peu publicité pc
pourquoi pas vous parler d'une page
facebook donc héritage 9 7 2 voilà donc
il y aura des modules d'information
comme ancrer sa liste citoyenne
justement dans le cadre des municipales
donc là au moins c'est clair et
transparent on a bien compris que vous
vous inscrivez aussi dans dans ce
rendez-vous de cette prochaine échéance
électorale
pour terminer sur le glacier président
de héritage de 7,2 vous avez eu
l'occasion de dire un moment que vous
voulez faire vis dénominateur commun ici
chez nous d'ailleurs qui qui dépasse les
générations enfin trans générationnel
qui voulait fédérer parce que la
martinique a droit et doit donc comment
dirais-je mettre en oeuvre son
aspiration à la liberté de sa société
civile voilà donc c'est ça que vous
allez un petit peu mais je pense que
trois fois oui la martinique pour jouer
en pologne pourrait proposer même des
indes et certains modèles ou solution de
paix notamment même à la france
hexagonale
oui je pense qu'on peut apporter
certaines choses et qu'on oublie souvent
et fédérer je pense que c'est la force
parce que malgré les différends qu'on
peut voir etc
on arrive quand même à vivre ensemble et
ça c'est pas le cas de tout le monde
d'ailleurs donc je pense qu'on peut être
un modèle mais il faut y aller il faut
il faut y aller on n'a plus le temps
on n'a plus le temps votre initiative
de la part des maires qui se déclarent
proches ou soutiens des manuels macron
comment il envisage sa est ce que vous
avez eu des retours plutôt positif en
bref parce qu'il faut compter en bref
est là il faudra demander à la reine
parce que ça n'est plus moi en revanche
la formation enfin on appelle ça la
formation en fait c'est pas une
formation comme d'habitude c'est des
modules d'information plus approfondie
c'est accessible à tout le monde donc la
personne qui est sans emploi comme le
conseiller municipal s'est ouvert à tout
le monde
donc ils sont aussi les bienvenus merci
charlotte grâce gressier d'avoir répondu
à nos questions aujourd'hui je vous
souhaite ainsi qu'à cannes aux
auditrices et nos auditeurs y compris
sur internet une très bonne journée
à bientôt